يترقب العالم الانتخابات التركيه والصراع
ما بين كمال كاليستار اوغلو والرئيس
الحالي اردوغان الذي قاد البلاد لمده
عقدين ويقاتل بشراسه للفوز بعقد ثالث في
الحكم التركي ولكن لماذا الانتخابات
التركيه مهمه جدا للعالم اجمع سؤال طرحته
وصحيفه
في ظل حكم اردوغان نمى دور تركيا كوسيط
اقليمي ودولي بشكل كبير وسيتم مراقبه
نتائج الانتخابات عن كثب في اوروبا وحلف
شمال الاطلسي والناتو تقول هنا صحيفه طبعا
وربما لن تراقب اي دوله اوروبيه
الانتخابات التركيه عن قرب اكثر من السويد
التي عرقل اردوغان محاولتها لتصبح عضوا في
حلف شمال الاطلسي على الرغم من ان تركيا
صوتت الشهر الماضي لسماح لفنلندا
بالانضمام الى النيتو في وقت اكدت
المعارضه التركيه انه في حال فوز هذه
المعارضه لن يكون عقب بوجه طموحات السويد
ووعدت بتنشيط العلاقات التركيه المتوتره
مع اوروبا والتعاون بشان ملف الهجره
الانتخابات التركيه مشاهدينا مهمه ايضا
لمسار الحرب في اوكرانيا لسببين رئيسيين
اولا لان تركيا طرحت نفسها وسيطا واستضافه
جوله اوليه من المحادثات الدبلوماسيه بين
موسكو
والتي سرعان ما تلاشت مع الشداد طبعا
وتيره الحرب والصراع اما السبب الثاني
فيكمن بمساعده انقره لتوقيع الاتفاق
الاممي الاستئناف شحنات الحبوب التي كانت
روسيا قد حاصرتها
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات